hey guys it's max today we are going to
be doing a ram
multitasking showdown comparing a brand
new
11 gen intel windows pc with eight gigs
of standard ram that we've been using
for years
against apple's macbook air that does
cost 200
less also has eight gigs of ram but it
is unified
memory a lot of people have talked
really good things about this unified
memory
and today we're gonna see how does it
compare in the real world
let's go ahead and get started by
opening up our activity monitor and
comparing ram usage
just sitting here at our desktop it
looks like the m1 mac is using
5.3 gigabytes of ram and we have some
cache files
but nothing is yet in swap meaning
nothing is written to the ssd
let me go ahead and open up the lg over
here the lg gram
and it looks like we're only using 3.7
gigabytes
on the lg so we're using actually less
with windows so far
and both these have the same
applications open now let's go ahead and
open up
google chrome i'm going to be using
chrome on both these systems
that way we keep it fair and let's go
ahead and open
say maybe five different websites just
so we get that kind of a standard
baseline
usage let's go ahead and open up a
youtube video how about this
positive jazz just for some background
music let's open up maybe a stock chart
that might auto update
in the background and then let's do
google drive this typically takes up a
fair bit of ram since i have
so much stuff in my google drive and
let's just go ahead and scan all the way
down so you guys can
screen grab what i have saved in here
and let's see how fluid this is so so
far
with five tabs open and not much else
the experience
is very similar and then let's quickly
just flick through some of these tabs
no issues whatsoever and i suspect
on our mac same thing super fluid now we
should know by now
that the m1 macbook air is faster than
this 11 gen intel
laptop but we're looking at is
responsiveness
and more like any slowdowns when you
have programs opened up to see
how ram compares so the performance in
between these two shouldn't
make a difference in this test
specifically and let's take a quick peek
at our activity monitor to see if ram
has changed
looks like it went up just by a little
bit on the m1 max still no swap
and here it looks like went up to 4.8
gigs so about a gig
higher than we had before and now let's
go ahead
and open up lightroom classic now keep
in mind the lightroom classic is still
using rosetta it hasn't optimized but
the performance is still good as you
guys see
with only five tabs open everything is
super smooth with these
raw 42 megapixel images i suspect
the intel system is also going to be
super smooth zooming in there no issues
let's go ahead and flip through a few of
these photos each one has a ton of
effects that have to be
done as i flip through so the
performance is pretty good
very little delay there same thing on
our m1 mac
now brushes could really hit a system
hard it uses both cpu and graphics and
as you see
on the m1 we get a slight delay there at
the start very small glitch
and then it's perfectly smooth at least
for now
and let's test out the intel system very
smooth looks like it might be actually
a little bit smoother at the start there
nope
also a tiny bit of delay and then it
smooths out and now we're going to get a
baseline reading
as far as exporting 50 of these images
and i think this is going to get re hit
really hard once we start opening up a
few more programs
and a lot more tabs let's check our vm
usage with this similar
intense task looks like we have six and
a
half
gigs used of physical memory compared to
6.2 very similar
uh but we have over four gigs of swap
used
on the m1 mac now on the lg it's tougher
to tell exactly
how much is being used but our committed
memory is at 16.2 gig so it's giving us
about eight gigs
of ssd space and the ssd on this lg is
actually faster than the macbook air now
if we open up
our performance monitor we'll see that
we're using about maybe
30 percent of the ssd's
capacity that we can use for ram and we
are done here our m1 mac took 2 minutes
and 41 seconds compared to 4 minutes and
17
seconds but let's go ahead and see what
happens when we open up some more web
browsing tabs and maybe another program
bam that is the 15th tab right over
there
and let's just scroll down all right web
browsing performance is still
pretty smooth all right all the on the
lg
also not bad and let's go ahead and open
up our google drive i'll open it up
at the same time whoa
looks like we just had to reload that
on the lg where's it opened up instantly
on our macbook pro how about our gme
stock
same thing all right let's go ahead and
try our youtube video that we had opened
up
it's still playing on both we still have
some calm jazz music
and how about ign over here
looks like it had to reload on the lg
and let's go back
to my google drive and let's try to do a
little bit of scrolling there see
if one is slowing down i know google
drive can really slow
down all right so once it's loaded both
are actually handling
this pretty well but of course we have
to reload everything
on the lg so it looks like windows is
playing a little bit unfairly
by shutting down those web tabs and
causing you to completely reload it
in order to save on ram where the mac
it's quick and it's still there now
taking a look at
our usage here both about six and a half
gigs
but the committed uh ssd has actually
shot up on our lg and here we have six
gigs of swap
now what i want to do is go ahead and
open up um our
lightroom which we haven't touched since
we've opened up all those tabs
so let's click at the same time and that
was fast
instant on both of them let's go ahead
and zoom in on this
very similar maybe a tiny bit of lag on
the lg
and let's flip through our photos looks
like the lg's
probably about the same so no problems
yet now what if you need an additional
professional application
i'm going to go ahead and open up
photoshop here and now i'm going to open
up
just five of these raw images without
any
effects on both systems and let's see
what kind of performance we get with
these images opened up so no
issues let's go and jump to the first
image
looks like the m1 is faster let's hop
back into google chrome
and we are looking like we got stuck
there
let me switch over to ign bam it was
instant there
so it looks like it actually might be
because we're reading from the ssd
because i didn't see anything reload it
just took a while
just to show up so let's go ahead and
flip back to our
google drive here once again you guys
saw how the m1 is
instant there this took a while how
about we go to
my gmail same thing how about
i diverge here all right that was fast
on both
so it looks like maybe the lg decided to
bring back those tabs and get it ready
if it knows that i'm
actively web browsing and let's test out
our scrolling performance
we have nothing really going on in the
background we just have those apps open
so far it looks like the m1 has
everything loaded up
whereas we're loading stuff on the lg
and
we got to the top here whereas with the
lg once we're getting to the top it has
to reload it
and now let's go down and see how it is
opening up
our lightroom classic which we haven't
touched in a while
not bad and let me scroll down my google
drive wow okay
i can't believe it even with eight gigs
of ram this is still perfectly smooth
and on the lg
still looking great both of these are
doing way better than i expected
6.6 gigs use that had a 7.7 but we have
a massive
27 gigs committed a ton is being written
to the ssd
and on our mac 11.8 gigs of swap
written to ssd but you guys see how
responsive that is
even working off of the ssd this just
makes you think is it even worth
spending extra money on 16 gigs vadim
did a video on ssd life
yesterday and on swap and off if that
matters if you should be worrying about
your ssd life
you guys should definitely check that
out i'll link that after this video
and now it's time for the moment of
truth how they perform
when we actually give them some work to
do instead of just simply opening up
tabs and
programs that should be in the
background so we're going to export
these 50 images again i'm going to hit
start and i'm just very curious on how
these are going to stack up
oh no lightroom it's is it crashing
did you guys see that it hasn't even
started exporting yet our mac
is off it's been about a minute
definitely behind where
it was previously and we have
a little bit under 10 gigs of swap being
used okay it is exporting but
it is just being weird no right it's
going
i'm not gonna touch this at all it is
just not being happy
looks like task manager had to reload
there
but we're up to 28 gigs committed 24 out
of 28 there
seven gigs used so very similar numbers
here
now as we're exporting you guys see
everything is kind of slowing down
let me open up my chrome very slow
of course we are using a lot of cpu
power as well and let's just quickly
switch these tabs and bam right there
you guys could see
we are having to pull these from our ssd
definitely slowing down now but we are
exporting using the cpu and the graphics
and let's test out our lg also very slow
definitely slower than the mac and
that's interesting because the ssd in
this system
is actually probably about twenty
percent
thirty percent faster so we have our
times and the m on mac took eight
minutes and five seconds compared to 13
minutes and 15 seconds
for the lg now that is of course a big
difference
in performance but if we look back at
our original testing
that's about three times longer than the
original for both systems a little bit
longer
on the lg there so it looks like
the performance penalty for having our
systems filled up with
all those tabs is pretty much the same
let's open up premiere pro and let's see
if that finally
can break this lg compared to the mac
or if they're still going to perform the
same well the mac loaded this program up
basically twice as fast we're still
loading up here
so maybe even it's gonna get to three
times as fast we see
we're having some issues all right there
you go
now it's loaded up and i don't think
that this lg can play back up full res
but it could do that
half so let's set both to half
and let's hit play
and our m1 is playing this back
perfectly
whereas the lg is playing it back at
about 10 frames per second
1011 out of i believe this is this
project's 24 so we're getting a bunch of
drop frames
and this project previously played back
perfectly when we didn't have the ram
all filled up
so that is already telling us something
now let me open up a different one
oh man we're glitching up here come on
i have the beta version of premiere pro
which is actually fairly buggy
on the m1 and the full release on this
lg here
come on stop all right let's switch this
back
to half performance so let's see how
that plays
this project is 30 frames per second
here
we're playing back at one we have
another background project open in the
background so there's two projects open
right now
let's make this even tougher on the m1
macbook air
we're at full resolution 4k here not
half resolution
all right let's see what's happening all
right two frames per second
keep in mind this has uh double the
resolution right now
all right so i didn't play it back
perfectly maybe i should have expected
that
let's pause it and switch over to half
it's playing back
nice and smoothly we're bouncing right
at 30 frames per second there
both at half resolution and the lg
all right it's not doing anywhere near
as good and it did once again played
this back
perfectly when the ram wasn't full
filled up
in our previous comparison so
basically the performance hit is about
half with the ram filled up
where here we have still have enough
power now of course as we were doing all
of this i'm sure some of that
background ram was written to the ssd
wow we have 15 gigs of swap
right now on the m1 unfortunately
here we don't know exactly how much but
we have 30 gigs committed that
is crazy and now let the paint begin
we are gonna try exporting this project
i'm gonna hit q
at the same time let's see which one
opens up quicker here
um i don't know maybe they're both quite
slow definitely slower than before
oh no the windows is freezing up on us
all right bam
looks like the m1 opened quicker and
that's interesting because previously
um the lg opened up faster and let's
hit start now previously the m1 was
a lot faster we already know that but we
want to see the difference in
performance
with ram filled up alright wow okay this
is crazy i did not expect this to be
happening
it looks like our m1 is almost as fast
as it was
without anything loaded up whereas the
lg
instead of 30 minutes it's gonna take
about an hour and
five an hour and seven minutes all right
guys i did not want to wait that long
for the lg to finish up
so let's go ahead and do one final test
we have
a bunch of stuff loaded up premiere
lightroom photoshop
let's go ahead and open up our chrome
here
all right so i'm on google drive there
let me switch over to google drive here
and let's see after all of that actually
i'm very curious how much swap is you
see on activity monitor
17.9 gigs almost 18 gigs is used up of
swap
that is absolutely insane so let's go
ahead and switch through
some of these tabs so our video is still
playing
that looks like it ah maybe completely
reset
another reset there emails resetting
okay that actually completely reloaded i
wasn't just pulling from the
ssd so looks like
windows and lg completely got rid of
all of these pages yeah i'm seeing
little loading icons right there
so they were not able to keep it over
that just pushed it too far
where now you have every single page is
reloading
because we had all of those programs
open once once we started exporting it
just
it killed it but it's still impressive
that the system didn't crash
let's take a look on our macbook
okay that's playing
look at that look how fast let me go
even faster than this
okay a little slower in that tab wow
okay no reloading i think one tab was
slower
everything else excellent
and then of course we can let's try
going back to lightroom
took a little bit longer than last time
that right there opened up quickly so
what is the verdict well first off the
lg with eight gigs of ram running
windows
actually performed better than i
expected um you know at the start when
we started loading up different tabs
yeah it was a little bit slower with 15
tabs open in lightroom than the
m1 macbook air which stayed perfectly
consistent
having five tabs open with nothing else
and having 15 of lightroom
but the difference wasn't that big now
as we added on more and more programs
when the task got tougher we did
starting to we started to get a bigger
gap between the two ending up
in premiere pro where the m1 macbook air
still stayed
almost as good as having nothing else
opened and the export was almost as fast
compared to lg where it really slowed
down and then of course afterwards those
tabs
they were just trashed at that point
where the m1
still was able to open up quickly once
we were done with the
export so overall yes we have a
difference it's not as big as i expected
and
one thing i want to note uh when i
compare the macbook pro with 16 gigs
of unified memory compared to the dell
xps with 16 gigs that was a much
shorter test but we saw a bigger gap
where the 16 gig m1 actually stayed
basically the same performance even
loaded up with a bunch of stuff like in
this video whereas the dell was 16
slowed down
quite a bit so it seems like 16 gigs is
really
the sweet spot and that's probably what
i would recommend now if you're somebody
that is
wanting to buy m1 or you already did and
you're worried about ssd longevity the
team did an excellent video right over
there you guys should definitely check
it out
and if you're interested in this lg we
have a review on it right over there
and it is a very nice machine with some
really good unique features
you can also click up there to subscribe
thank you guys for watching this max and
i'll see you in the next video